katmandou au pied de l'himalaya
katmandou son art de vivre sa sagesse et
ses temples
[Musique]
depuis que le roi du népal est tombé
c'est katmandou la reine les
investisseurs se ruant ville et tirent
leurs cartes du jeu ils construisent à
coups de dollars de béton et de briques
face à la frénésie des hommes je décide
de sortir mon atout pis nous parlera
bhattarai et urbaniste 20 ans il n'y
avait qu'un quart de ce que vous voyez
là 40% de la population du pays est
maintenant installée dans la vallée on a
construit dans tous les sens et sans
logique en se moquant des risques de
tremblements de terre
un jour on mourra tous rien ne restera
devant l'isle d'abeau alors d'accord ça
fait 2000 on confie briques des briques
mais la vallée de katmandou c'est la
plus belle terre agricole bonne année
donnée c'est une honte de fabriquer des
briques averses allaient voir par
vous-mêmes vous verrez la réalité des
lieux aux usa
sans attendre le prochain tremblement de
terre je me mets en quête des
briqueteries première brique à gauche 3e
pic à droite mais chaque fois un projet
de construction au milieu d'un tas de
briques
ce n'est que le lendemain matin en marge
de la ville que je découvre enfin la
vallée des briqueteries deschamps de
briques à perte de vue
chaque jour le soleil se lève derrière
les cheminées la vie elle derrière les
murs 120 briqueterie produisent à elles
seules un milliard de briques parents à
les regarder de plus près les hommes
donnent ici la sensation d'être enfermés
dehors
à y regarder de plus haut ils ne font
que travailler au moule la terre avec la
sueur de son front
on apprend très jeune à donner à ses
rêves la forme d'une brique qu'on
laissera ses chiens en plein soleil
l'économie du geste pour mieux gagner sa
vie aller chercher la terre c'est dur
mouler les briques c'est dur aussi mené
les monts lagarde
les entasser en mur pour les sécher
c'est encore plus dur
je travaille depuis que j'en suis
capable
elle n'a pas si on était instruit on
n'aurait pas à souffrir comme ça m'a
bien dure on n'a pas d'argent
la fête c'est tout ce que je peux vous
dire moi c'est comme ça c'est vrai qu'on
pourrait faire plein de choses si on
avait de larges et ouvrira une boutique
par exemple ce serait plus facile ça
nous donnerait doute l'opportunité et le
policier les grilles c'est l'argent qui
fait tout aujourd'hui
auparavant on espérait croyez en dieu
ils sont passés par là dieu n'a plus de
valeur
aujourd'hui on chie même dans les temps
les rêves nous renvoie à nos propres
souffrances
si on travaille pas aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qu'on mangera demain
[Musique]
la vraie
triste constat autant jouer cartes sur
table pour cent briques aujourd'hui t'as
plus rien même pas un peu d'espoir
j'étais prêt à quitter la partie quand
la vie m'a rappelé il était midi
[Applaudissements]
à midi sur une briqueterie les rêves ne
sache pas il dessèche
j'étais prêt à partir d'hier quand j'ai
vu l'espoir faire le mur et se moquer du
chagrin
il y avait des façons de voir la vie et
les briqueteries celle des désespérés et
celle de bi bec 32 ans porteur d'un tout
autre message
parfois c'est très violent et les
briques tombe on les retire alors de mon
salaire mais c'est la vie de toute façon
quand on porte c'est toujours trop lourd
quand on travaille c'est toujours trop
dur des jeux gagnent 10 roupies pour
cent briques mais je fais 100 à 160
voyages par jour
alors non je ne me plains pas
et puis tu sais je suis pas tout seul
ici c'est d aimer mon village
c'est sympa on passe du bon temps
ensemble on se fait débat d'entre nous
on s'amuse le temps passe sans même
qu'on s'en rende compte
mais bon là je dois y retourner moi j'ai
pris du retard
le patron va finir par aller sinon comme
prévu le patron à râler et la nuit est
tombée
[Musique]
je me suis réveillée au fond du trou la
gueule dans le charbon
mais le coeur réchauffé par l'espoir il
n'y a pas de bonheur sans souffrance à
de briques sont fumées il faut faire
avancer le feu de telle sorte qu'il y
ait toujours des briques cuites et des
briques à cuire comme il ya les rêves et
le souvenir
[Musique]
la recette est simple préchauffez votre
four à 1000 degrés rajouter du charbon
toutes les 20 minutes
vérifier la température saupoudrez le
tout d'un peu d'espoir je pouvais alors
enfournez et laissez cuire pendant deux
jours
[Musique]
600 hommes par briqueterie s'activent
ainsi en permanence
certains portent des briques comme un
fardeau d'autres se disent que le poids
des rêves n'est jamais trop lourd à
porter en cumulant les voyages au cumul
des jetons qu'on échangera plus tard
contre des roupies
le patron a beau être à l'heure il est
bon payeur il ya quelques années il
n'était qu'un simple comptable dans une
briqueterie fait c'est maintenant lui
l'as de la brique l'alchimie des
alpilles et à pleyel fait je m'appelle
ltée comme les bric
je suis le premier dans la vallée avoir
commencé à écrire mes initiales sur lui
maintenant tout le monde cherche à mi
mai qu'il ne savait pas il ya plus
important que les apparences même que le
capital comme mois d'été ce sont les
ouvriers car sans eux on ne peut pas
pour moi c'est eux le plus important ce
matin parfois ils se bagarrent d'autres
fois ils peuvent décider de quitter la
briqueterie sans raison mon métier c'est
de trouver le moyen de les faire rester
c'est dans cette logique que nous
récompensons les meilleurs c'est pour ça
que j'aime ce que je fais
mais aussi parce que je considère la
brique comme un produit de première
nécessité à j'aimerais bien que mes
enfants prennent le relais ce serait une
satisfaction pour moi mais d'un autre
côté mon père était paysan il souhaitait
que je fasse comme lui et aujourd'hui je
ne suis pas mécontent que nous fûmes 1
et diverger
malgré les différences on ne s'éloigne
jamais complètement de ses racines avec
la terre et l'eau on peut soit décider
de faire pousser du riz soit des briques
il appartient ensuite à chacun de jouer
les alchimistes et d'appliquer sa propre
recette à chacun de décider quel avenir
donner à son tas de boue
[Musique]
chaque soir en fait ainsi les comptes
quand la journée est assez bonne on se
donne rendez vous chez be bec pour une
petite partie entre amis
l'occasion pour moi de savoir si entre
deux cartes
il a déjà songé à l'avenir
[Musique]
je vais te dire comment je vois les
choses
depuis tout petits ont fait grandir des
rêves mais le temps passe et on vieillit
à ceux qui possèdent des terres et qui
deviendront paysans il ya ceux qui
sentent la nécessité de partir pour
d'autres projets moi je suis venu ici
pour tenter ma chance j'ai envie de
devenir riche en centaines de milliers
de roupies et regarder les autres
réussir ça m'apporte rien j'ai décidé de
me mettre en danger parce qu'attendre de
free du ciel c'est mourir en contemplant
[Musique]
reste qu'une fois qu'on a accumulé assez
de briques pour réaliser son rêve il
faut encore prendre soin de ne pas tout
en l'air car une même briques
peut servir à construire une prison ou
un palais à katmandou chacun est en
train d'édifier le sien mais au moindre
tremblement de terre les rêves risque de
s'effondrer